tell you man every year November
December well as Hollywood do Oscar Bay
movies just like this one incarnate
I think that's name of the hold on and
garnet so incarnate stars Aaron Eckhart
it's actually really hard maybe to
describe so this little kid who is the
kid who plays Bruce Wayne in the TV show
Gotham he gets possessed by this demon
Aaron Eckhart is kind of an exorcist but
kind of not what he is is he's a psychic
who can go inside a person who's
possessed you can go inside their mind
kick the demon out and save the person's
he has like inception the cell
dreamscape Meets The Exorcist so here we
are this is just the movie let's talk
about it all right what I liked about
this movie is the take they have on
possession and exorcisms not really a
religious thing these aren't actually
demons from Hell or anything like that
just goes on it's basically an energist
moving it's like ah sometimes it's
called Chi sometimes it's called aura
what it is is the energy the human body
gives each person has a different
signature his negative energy entities
latch onto that and so that's how a
person becomes possessed very much an
energy parasite which is a way of
explaining a demon I really if that's
exactly what a demon is it's just
without the religious twist to it I
thought that was really interesting
they're going a different route also I
do like seeing someone go inside
someone's mind no matter what I just
find it interesting the angle that this
movie plays and goes for is actually a
fascinating one and it's not as shitty
as I thought it was going to be
execution-wise it's not good I'm not
gonna just tear ass into this movie
there are problems with it though we're
spell Aaron Eckhart you get it touching
the fact that Harvey Dent and Bruce
Wayne are in this movie together I just
blow your mind whoever you need that to
but Israel Aaron Eckhart actually makes
his attempt and brings it in whatever he
does this would be still those trying to
kid in this movie I've seen him in a few
things now and bit I'm starting to
wonder if he's OneNote I mean he's good
in the roles he's in but every role he
is in is a kid who's very stoic and
monotone and that's what he does he does
it well but that's what he does with
that dudes there's some pacing [ __ ] in
here no matter how interesting the
premise is when you hear about it and
when you see it executed in parts in the
she's totally speaking and facing wise
you're like this is kind of a wreck are
you really is he there's one part where
he goes to see this dude and this dude
is also possessed by Damian and dude
kills himself and he gets back to the
house where he's doing that you know
mental exorcism thing and the moms like
where were you and he was like I had to
go get something oh okay
there's there's not a body like no one
died right in front because I was
thinking I was like that scene is so
detached I really feel like initially he
went to go get something and then he
came back and they were like oh we need
someone to die to make it interesting
because we was kind of dragging on so
let's just have someone die all right
reshoots free film let's do it all right
now it's refilmed and now we just kind
of shoehorn it in there this could be
considered a spoiler it's not it doesn't
matter no like I'm ruining a rival for
you it's fine anyhow they get the dad he
comes back the dad just eat [ __ ] and
dies no like well that didn't work out
no it didn't it also didn't add anything
to the movie it did nothing it didn't
move the plot a lot why did that happen
I feel like this movie's gonna be about
an hour-long made-for-tv episode of
something in there like can we drag it
out for about a half an hour more I just
put a couple more things in there there
we go we now have something that can
constitute a theatrically released
motion picture is long enough so now hey
let's release it theater guys in the end
this movie wasn't [ __ ] it was not
spoiler alert for me it's not dark [ __ ]
I thought it was going to be it's not
it's not good it's like a movie that's
on TV you're like my nutters on Netflix
or Amazon Prime because everyone has
that so you watch it for free somehow
get a couple rum and cokes have fun
you're like all right incarnate is
probably a better time if you're drunk
yeah no it's a buddy Aaron Eckhart
you're better than this I've seen you be
better than this
but do something that's better if you
don't start picking good roles this is
going to be you not knowing you're being
filmed right guys so incarnate have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here you wanna see more
click right here to say more
[Music]